high-ranking government officials or
billionaire businessmen can soar above
the traffic but most others have to rely
on ferries or wait for hours in the
gridlock seven and a half million people
live in Hong Kong the tunnel is supposed
to help alleviate congestion it's being
built 50 metres below sea level some
parts are already completed
16 years old mother standing in a tunnel
that's all about innovation first of all
it's the world's biggest tunnel of its
kind uses the biggest boring machine
because of the difficult geology rock
soft ground 5 bar water pressure and the
cross passages its unique possible bond
antique fairs l'église de una cart the
project is a French joint venture based
in Hong Kong the tunnel boring machines
come from Germany conditions here have
been difficult yes it's the first time
we we are at five bar pressure 45
kilometres with with a lot of work
excavation so we need to we need to dive
every day we need to send people to
change these cutters in idea by
conditions on a daily basis it's a
chaotic scene right now but in the
not-too-distant future two and three
lanes of traffic will be flowing through
here building the tunnel and a heavy
water pressure as a special challenge
Martin heaven connects company is the
global market leader in specialised
boring machines and look how tired this
absolute war of time the tunnel boring
machine has a diameter of 17 point 6
meters a world record even the recently
completed Swiss got hard tunnel was
built with smaller machinery in good
shape everybody as you can see here the
the front of the machine is a zero and
three millimeter apart from the
theoretical and the back of the machine
is mine minus 2 millimeter minus 16
minute or so you can you can steer a 14
meter diameter tbm with very good
accuracy the parts to build the casing
come from China heaven Knecht has a
production facility there the
engineering expertise came from Germany
challenging chops challenging jobs that
bring technology forward and top-notch
work that's all here at the construction
site
health care browse to the mega tunnel is
slated for completion by the end of 2018
until then the privileged few will have
to stick to their helicopters to get to
the airport